say okay to babies this is your book
when I know for a fact the Lord Moses
says you shall not let your children
pass through the fire
you I show you I'm to show you I can
show you man I can show you a when we
attack our enemies and thisis as well we
wipe you all out even your children I
can show you that okay Samuel here okay
let read Samuel to you here this the
Bible the Old Testament
people over Israel now therefore he
voice the words of the Lord thus says
the Lord of host I will punish am for
what he did to Israel how he Ambush him
on way where's his car on car on don't
stop okay he stopped okay stopped now go
and attack Malik and utterly destroy all
that they have and do not spare them but
kill both men and women infants and
nurses child so in the B it's okay to
kill babies if there are enemies yeah we
wipe them babies are enemies now babies
are enemies that's why you that's why
you defending zist that makes sense
because you have no problem for babies
to be killed that's why you defending
zist it's unbelievable
bro yeah there's nothing me there's
nothing show me so you're saying we
can't defend ourselves and gu babies so
everybody out that's why and he has the
gut to speak mam
you just say that the festin are
killing Anyway by the way this this guy
he came claiming that is extremist and
so on and he's standing here saying it's
okay to kill a babies to them why you're
trying to look at everybody else it's
unbelievable brother I think you should
be I think you should be on the watch
list if you think it's okay to kill
babies yeah if you think it's okay to
kill babies bro trust me
they do the same thing to go WIP out all
the enemies of Israel babies enemy
everybody enemies bab enemy you know why
when their children grow up like the
Palestinian children right what do they
do what
theyan what are they doing right now
with the
children I no train to attack you
stoping I will show you I will show you
where the Tre and that's why it says
that don't
bring to children when you yourself
believe it's okay no no it's Haram I say
okay Isis have done it are evil not
Islam what palestin they're not evil
Palestinian pales children stop
lying
anyway
jusy
H H govern in Terrorist to go and
attack St
H make sense
you against extremism right I ask them
about an event in their prophets you're
aiming at me cuz I'm white think listen
you're saying what I'm saying is the the
I'm listening but they're saying you're
saying the Palestinian people they what
ham evil listen V terrorist so what
about the Jewish they're killing
Palestinians on a daily basis on a daily
basis defend himself against babies what
about the Palestinians 1948 been killed
he has no to be Ked he has no for
children to be K this situation is very
is going to get you should be watch you
should be in the watch L bro you
standing here just to find the of
babies terrorist
group one man's terrorist is another
man's Freedom Fighter one man
look no it's not any children it's not
okay to any children terorist I'm not
defending first no no firstly I don't
agree with
you fighting for your country doesn't
make it terrorist fighting for your
country doesn't make it terrorist
because why it's known that listen
listen know that's going to be a holiday
look Gaza so you want to kill babies and
children again back to her did I say
that you did you said the babies are
enemies that's what you said and you're
standing here you're
defending of course I'm
aoud I defend paltin all day long
brother op on the October H H did do
that H did do that but what about the
years before what about the years
before nonsense you standing here by the
way you know he started he tried to
against muhamad weh M clearly said do
not kill a women and children and he
saying it's okay to kill babies and
children that's why you support Zionist
it makes sense now anyway take care of
yourself look yourself